[Applaus]
[Musik]
wenn es die europäische union nicht
schon geben würde müssten politiker sie
einfach erfinden denn wo sonst könnten
sie so verlässlich ihre ganzen fa-cups
schieben
[Musik]
auf ein killervirus nach hoffentlich
werden sie nicht jedes jahr die
gelegenheit dazu haben nein der
langfristig verlässliche perfekte
sündenbock ist und bleibt die denn immer
wenn die idee in einem land gut laufen
ist dies natürlich das verdienst der
jeweiligen nationalen regierung aber
wenn mal wieder alles schief geht ist
genau wer allem schuld genau diese
furchtbare eben diese polit folklore ist
mittlerweile fester bestandteil des
politischen spektrums geworden ob links
oder rechts von der mitte
wieso sollte gerade dies in der kroner
krise also anders sein als die üblichen
verdächtigen kommen jetzt aus ihren
löchern gekrochen und klagen an wie ist
es verdammt noch mal möglich dass die
europäische union nichts gegen korona
getan habt dabei müsste die eigentliche
frage doch lauten was hätte die eu
überhaupt tun können ja das ist mein
voller ernst denkmal einen moment
darüber nach für gesundheitspolitik und
die damit verbundenen budgets sind
einzig und allein die einzelnen
nationalstaaten zuständig und dasselbe
gilt für die verschiedenen gesundheits
und krankenversicherungssysteme in den
einzelnen mitgliedstaaten
viele leute glauben nun mal das ganz
europa so was wie ein einheitliches
öffentliches gesundheitssystem hat nur
weil es diese blauen europäischen
krankenversicherungskarte gibt
tatsächlich sieht es aber ganz anders
aus in der eu gibt es nämlich zwei große
sich grundsätzlich voneinander
unterscheidende modelle der
gesundheitsversorgung ok welche werden
das hättet ihr eine idee
nun da wäre zum einen das sogenannte
beverage system welches nach nord
beverage benannt ist der einer
kommission vorsaß die nach dem zweiten
weltkrieg das britische gesundheitswesen
reformierte es beruht auf dem prinzip
dass das gesamte gesundheitswesen also
alle krankenhäuser ärzte und notwendige
medikamente direkt aus der staatskasse
also aus steuermitteln finanziert werden
und allen bürgern zugänglich sind
allerdings kann man sich in barricks
system meistens den arzt oder die
behandlungseinrichtungen nicht selbst
aussuchen
sie werden jeden bürger fest zugewiesen
alles wird zentral vom start geplant und
bezahlt außer in großbritannien haben
dieses system auf baustellen spanien
dänemark und neuseeland übernommen
auf der anderen seite gibt es jedoch
noch das bismarck system genau das ist
nach dem deutschen reichskanzler otto
von bismarck genannt denn deutschland
führte unter seiner regierung bereits im
jahr 1883 als erstes land der welt die
gesetzliche krankenversicherung pflicht
ein kernstück des bismarckschen modells
ist dass die erbringung der gesundheits
versorgung durch krankenhäuser und freie
ärzte von der finanzierung der dadurch
entstehenden gesundheitskosten
unabhängig ist es stehen sich also
krankenversicherungen auf der einen und
die erbringer der gesundheitsversorgung
auf der anderen seite gegenüber es gibt
also so etwas mit einem markt der staat
greift zwar regulierend ein aber
ansonsten kann ich mir weitgehend frei
aussuchen in welches krankenhaus also
welche hast ich gehe und eben auch schon
welche versicherung ich mir die kosten
finanzieren lassen heute haben in
deutschland auch viele andere länder wie
österreich ungarn tschechien oder
frankreich das bismarck system
übernommen ebenso wie die systeme an
sich schwanken jedoch auch die
gesundheitsbudgets von land zu land ganz
enorm
[Applaus]
das schlägt sich dann beispielsweise bei
der intensivpflege diene während
deutschland zum beispiel über 29
intensivbetten pro 100000 einwohner
verfügt sind es in spanien nur 9,7 und
den finder 6,1 gut und als es nun um die
maßnahmen im kampf gegen kopitz hingegen
welche art waren diese maßnahmen erster
linie nun schulschließungen liegen zum
beispiel im kompetenzbereich der schul
und kultusministerien diese können also
nur die nationalstaaten beschließen oder
wie in deutschland sogar nur die
einzelnen bundesländer ähnlich ist es
bei grenzschließungen ausgangs
beschränkungen der koordination von
polizei und armee all das fällt einfach
nicht in den kompetenzbereich der eu
dafür sind nur die einzelnen länder
zuständig es gibt jedoch die eu
institutionen die empfehlungen
aussprechen können und dies ist durchaus
geschehen aber seht mal was dann ans
limit wie staaten wie zum beispiel
spanien heraus gemacht haben
[Musik]
die feierlichkeiten am 8 märz von dem
entgegen den kriterien der europäischen
agentur statt aber es gibt noch eine
sache bei der die europäische union
helfen kann die wirtschaft und das liebe
freunde ist keine kleinigkeit niemand
weiß wie die welt nach der krise
aussehen wird aber eines ist klar wir
werden eine rezession ungeheuren
ausmaßes erleben wir haben große teile
unseres produktions gefüges für mehrere
wochen lahmgelegt viele unternehmen
werden schließen müssen da ihnen das
geld ausgeht oder ihre geschäftsmodelle
zerstört wurden das resultat sind
tausende und abertausende von
arbeitslosen wir haben wohl ein sehr
sehr schlechtes jahr für uns und das
praktisch weltweit
[Musik]
corona virus rekordzahl von amerikanern
meldet sich arbeitslos und wie ihr euch
vorstellen könnt müssen die regierungen
nun hilfspläne aufstellen es geht um die
verlängerung von krediten
steuerbefreiungen oder direkten
subventionen einige länder wie
deutschland österreich die usa
großbritannien und tschechien haben
bereits angekündigt das ist
überbrückungs leistungen für
selbstständige geben wird oder dass
diese für ein paar monate keine
sozialversicherungsbeiträge zahlen
müssen unterm strich bedeutet dies vor
allem die krone krise wird für alle sehr
sehr teuer und womit wird diese fette
krone rechnung beglichen werden
ganz einfach mit schuldenstaaten rund um
den globus werden massiv anleihen
ausgeben müssen deswegen konnte man sich
auch diesem hat darauf verlassen dass
wieder jene alte idee aus der schublade
gekramt wird über die in jeder krise
innerhalb der eurozone gestritten wird
eurobonds okay worum geht es dabei
nun im grunde ganz einfach darum dass
nicht mehr wie bisher jeder einzelne
staat seine eigenen staats anleihen
auflegt stattdessen soll es gemeinsame
anleihen für alle staaten der euro zone
geben dh die schulden werden auf alle
mitgliedsstaaten verteilt jeder haftet
für jeden ja und was meint ihr wer sich
auf die ausgabe dieser staatsanleihen am
allermeisten von allen freund russell
nun mit absoluter bestimmtheit kann ich
das auch nicht sagen aber wenn ich
tippen müsste würde ich sagen die
italienische mafia die freut sich auf
diese neuen euro bei uns schon wie
kleine kinder auf den weihnachtsmann hat
euch das jetzt etwas überrascht und
fragt ihr euch warum ich gerade auf die
italienische mafia komme dann passt
jetzt gut auf denn am ende dieses videos
werdet ihr genau verstehen warum gerade
diese verbrecherbande so viel freude an
europäischen staatsanleihen hätte
[Musik]
die deutschen und die niederländer
blockieren auch europäischer
video-konferenz die korona bonds der
europäischen union
schauen wir uns doch zunächst einmal die
offiziellen gegenspieler in diesem
nervenkrieg für einige von aber ich
würde das jetzt ein déjà vu sein denn es
handelt sich um nichts anderes als um
ein weiteres kapitel in der unendlichen
geschichte nordeuropa gegen süd europa
die nordländer treten für sparmaßnahmen
ein und die südländer wollen geld
ausgeben als ob es kein morgen gäbe und
wieder einmal brechen die alten wunden
und die gleichen spannungen innerhalb
europas auf wie bei jeder finanz oder
wirtschaftskrise und ihr könnt davon
ausgehen dass dieser streit auch diesmal
verdammt dreckig ablaufen wird
[Musik]
der portugiesische premierminister zum
beispiel hat bereits die erste
breitseite gefeuert als er die position
der niederlande als widerlich bezeichnet
die spanischen medien haben bereits
begonnen gegen die niederlande und
deutschland ordentlich stimmung zu
machen
und viele werden sich angesichts der
lage ganz berechtigt fragen geht es hier
nicht einfach um solidarität und sind
nicht eigentlich die niederlande und
deutschland die bösen egoisten wären
eurobonds oder wie sie es genannt werden
corona bonds nicht eine recht gute idee
zur lösung der durch die krise
verursachten finanzprobleme heute werden
wir diese frage beantworten aber zuerst
werden wir uns ein wenig mit der
geschichte beschäftigen neue
herausforderungen alte rezepte
finanzkrise von 2008 begann als eine
schuldenkrise der banken und mündete in
eine schuldenkrise der staaten
damals mussten portugal italien
griechenland und spanien massiv kredit
aufnehmen und ja ich habe diese länder
genau in dieser reihenfolge genannt weil
die internationale presse diesen ländern
die abkürzung egs6 verpasst hat p für
portugal italien griechenland und essen
für spanien die anspielung auf das
englische wort für schweine hatten die
urheber dieses kürzel es ganz bestimmt
nicht im sinne alles nur purer zufall
ich war nun was man aber ganz bestimmt
sagen kann ist dass diese pigs einen
schweine hunger hatten nach geld und
woher nehmen wenn nicht stehlen nun das
übliche ist die ausgabe von
staatsanleihen auf dem bondmarkt aber
was ist in bonn
auch schuldverschreibung oder anlage
genannt eigentlich nun es ist ein blatt
papier das zum beispiel von einem staat
herausgegeben wird und du als investor
kannst dieses stück papier für geld auf
auf diesem papier steht dass zum
beispiel spanien oder eben das
herausgebende land die ihr die geldsumme
die dusche das papier bei seiner
herausgabe bezahlt hast nach einer
festgelegten zeit wieder zurückzahlt
außerdem ist auf dem papier auch als
zinssatz festgelegt denn jedes jahr
zahlt ja der ausgebenden staat auch noch
zinsen dafür dass du ihm über die
anleihe ein sauer verdientes geld
geliehen hast klingt doch eigentlich die
ein gutes und sicheres geschäft oder
denn auch staaten kann man doch
vertrauen nun leider nicht ganz es gibt
länder die ihre schulden nicht
zurückzahlen und ihr können wir getrost
glauben dass wenn ein unternehmen euch
geld schuldet und dies nicht
zurückzahlen will
dann habt ihr ein problem denn ihr müsst
ist vor gericht zerren wenn der
schuldner aber kein unternehmen ist
sondern ein staat bleibt euch nichts
anderes übrig als zu beten
ich gebe euch ein beispiel
[Musik]
investoren bereiten sich auf verluste
bei den schulden verhandlungen mit
argentinien vor genau tausend investoren
die argentinien geld geliehen haben
gehen davon aus dass die ihr geld nie
wieder sehen werden stimmen diejenigen
die es waren aufzumucken uns darauf
hinzuweisen dass in argentinien
eigentlich schwarz auf weiß versprochen
hat das ihnen zustehende geld
zurückzuzahlen laufen gefahr als
aasgeier fonds oder finanz terroristen
beschimpft zu werden nun ebenfalls
spricht man eben von einem sehr hohen
ausfallrisiko und was passiert wenn ein
land ein hohes ausfallrisiko hat nun es
muss mehr zinsen auf diese schulden
zahlen mit anderen worten die investoren
vertrauen erst gar nicht darauf ihr geld
am ende zurück zu bekommen aber wenn der
staat ihnen verspricht jedes jahr ganz
viel zinsen zu bezahlen gehen sie dieses
risiko ein denn sie hoffen den
geliehenen betrag und vielleicht noch
etwas mehr wenigstens über die zinsen
zurückerhalten ein spiel auf zeit das
erklärt warum die 10 jährige
argentinische anleihe einen zinssatz von
sage und schreibe 30 prozent hat und die
deutsche minus 0,3 prozent ja das hast
du richtig gehört wenn du den deutschen
staat geld leisten bekommst du nicht nur
gar keine zinsen sondern du musst auch
noch geld dafür bezahlen dass der
deutsche fiskus mit seinem geld machen
kann was er will
und wieso ist das so nun weil alle
investoren deutschland unglaublich stark
vertrauen das ist seine schulden
zurückzahlt so sehr dass sich
deutschland sozusagen mit freude eine
kleine gebühr dafür bezahlen das ist für
10 jahre ihr geld so schön risikofreie
in obhut nimmt wer aber misst eigentlich
dieses risiko eines zahlungsausfalls nun
dafür gibt es spezialisierte unternehmen
die sogenannten ratingagenturen die drei
wichtigsten sind moody's fitch und
standard infos dieser agenturen wälzen
die rechnungsbücher eines landes
untersuchen seine wirtschaftsstruktur
bewerten die leistungsfähigkeit seiner
unternehmen und alle anderen
steuerzahler denn von diesen müssen die
schulden und zinsen ja letztendlich
erarbeitet und eingetrieben werden nach
der finanzkrise des jahres 2008 hatten
länder wie spanien riesige defizite
angehäuft dies bedeutete dass die
regierung vielmehr geldausgabe als sie
an steuern von ihren bürgern und
unternehmen einnahmen
hinzu kamen eine hohe arbeitslosigkeit
überall strukturprobleme und eine
grassierende korruption mit anderen
worten spaniens risiko seine schulden
irgendwann nicht mehr zurückzahlen zu
können war recht hoch
das ergebnis waren dann sehr hohe
zinssätze für die aufnahme neuer
schulden über staatsanleihen damit ihr
eine vorstellung bekommt dass dies kein
pappenstiel ist in spanien bild die
schuldzinsen auch heute noch den
drittgrößten posten im staatshaushalt
nur die zinsen von tilgungen ist da noch
nicht die rede
mit anderen worten wenn man nicht gerade
deutschland ist an geld leihen am
anleihenmarkt sehr treuer werk
aber moment mal denn es gibt für die
armen pigs noch eine billigere
alternative zum anleihenmarkt sie können
sich das geld doch auch ganz einfach von
einem freund morgen zu einem
freundschaftspreis natürlich also sehr
sehr niedrigen zinsen ist denn sowas
möglich ja ist es absolut in diesem fall
ist der freund die europäische union
tja liebe zuschauer die rede ist vom
gefürchteten euro-rettungsschirme dieser
vergibt darlehen mit sehr niedrigen
zinssätzen an euro staaten die ihre
schulden nicht mehr zurückzahlen
und jetzt fragt ihr euch sicher wo ist
da der hatten und die wirtschaftlichen
kosten dieser darlehen sind sehr niedrig
dafür sind aber die politischen kosten
sehr hoch ok wovon reden wir hier was
sind politische kosten also wenn die
europäische union einen rettet heißt
dies im grunde okay wir geben dir das
geld quasi für umme aber dafür will ich
die kontrolle darüber was du mit diesem
geld anstellt denn vertrauen ist gut
kontrolle ist besser
nun eigentlich kann man in diesem fall
gar nicht von vertrauen reden und glaubt
mir die geschichte hat gezeigt dass
europa sehr gute gründe hat den text
ganz und gar nicht zu vertrauen
während spanien zum beispiel damals
seine bis dahin schlimmste
wirtschaftskrise durchmachte leistete
sich madrid eine unglaublich
kostspielige kandidatur für den nächsten
olympischen spiele ganz zu schweigen von
all den politischen geschenken riesigen
korruptionsaffären ungerechtfertigten
steuerbelege für amigos und ihre
unternehmen und einer gewaltigen
schattenwirtschaft und je größer die
schattenwirtschaft eines landes desto
kleiner ist die fähigkeit des staates
steuern einzutreiben und daraus zu essen
zu bezahlen allein italien entgehen
dadurch über 100 milliarden euro
jährlich tja und in italien
es ist außerdem noch die mafia an jeder
ecke und lauert nur darauf ihren schnitt
durch überteuerte aufträge zur mission
gedruckt und jede andere nur erdenkliche
art der veruntreuung öffentlicher gelder
zu machen natürlich mit hilfe eines weit
verzweigten netzwerks korrupter
politiker mit anderen worten das
allerletzte was spanische italienische
und französische politiker wollen ist
das aus brüssel wieder die men in black
anrücken und überall ihre nase
reinstecken
[Musik]
die men in black waren jeder bösen
bürokraten und prüfer die den armen fix
politikern damals vorschreiben wollten
was sie zu tun und lassen haben damit
sie ihren finanziellen schweinestall
ausgemistet bekommen nein sowas mögen
die stolzen politiker dieser länder hat
nun mal gar nicht und genau in diesem
moment kam die europäische kommission
unterstützt von spanien und italien auf
eine grandiose idee
[Musik]
europäische kommission schlägt eurobonds
als waffe gegen die krise vor
was war da aber ist der hintergrund nun
investoren hatten damals keine besonders
große lust den pigs noch mehr geld zu
leihen da ihr vertrauen in die
finanzpolitik und zahlungsfähigkeit
dieser staaten nicht mehr allzu gross
war dem leistungsfähigen und
verlässlichen deutschland warfen sie ihr
geld jedoch mit freude hinterher
wieso also nicht beide extreme
miteinander vermischen um einen
erträglichen kompromiss für alles
eurobonds wären anleihen die schulden
von sehr kreditwürdigen und weniger
kreditwürdigen ländern miteinander
kombinieren würden mit anderen worten
würde es sich also um ein fest
verschnürtes paket handeln in denen die
schlechten schulden und die guten
schulden quasi gesteckt werden
deckt nur einen moment darüber nach für
einen zahlungsunfähige island sind
eurobonds das beste aus beiden welten
niedrige zinsen und kaum politische
kosten na das sind doch alles nur
vorteile
was für probleme gibt es denn dann damit
nun das problem ist dass eurobonds im
grunde auf demselben mechanismus bewohnt
der welt im jahr 2008 in die finanzkrise
geführt hat die geniale idee einiger
profitgier banker gute hypotheken
solventer schuldner mit ihren toxischen
hypotheken deren schuldner diese nie
würden zurückzahlen können in not
verschmierten vollkommen intransparenten
paketen zu bündeln und diese pakete dann
an den nächstgrößeren dummen zu
verkaufen denn die toxischen hypotheken
klein hätte ihn ja niemand abgekauft so
konnten sie sich die welt jedoch schön
rechnen und da die schulden bündel schön
komplex und untrennbar waren konnte man
sich quasi mit fantasie preisen versehen
die keiner richtig überprüfen konnte
alles was zählte war nur ein fester
glaube und das marketing
[Applaus]
dies führte dann natürlich dazu dass
eine bank nun gar keine hemmungen mehr
hatte viel zu große kredite an menschen
zu vergeben von denen sie eigentlich
wusste dass sie diese nie würden
zurückzahlen können denn sobald ein
kreditvertrag abgeschlossen war wurde er
in ein dicht verschlossenes paket mit
anderen trikot gepackt und weiter
verkauft die bank bekamen so schnell
wieder ihr ganzes geld zurück und konnte
schön boni an ihre banker auszahlt nun
das funktionierte eben nur so lange gut
bis der vorrat an nächstgrößeren idioten
die bereit waren diese mogelpackungen
abzukaufen herrscht
[Applaus]
dann lasst diese ganze illusion und ich
kann euch sagen das war damals eine
wirklich vertrackte krise denn überall
in den büchern aller möglichen banken
lagen diese kredit bitten darum von
denen nun gar keiner mehr wusste wie ich
die eigentlichen wert waren keiner
vertraute mehr keinem und niemand wusste
wie lange es dauern würde dieses ganze
schlamassel wieder zu entflechten
die guten von den schlechten krediten zu
trennen und dann irgendwann wieder mit
dem normalen kreditgeschäft weiter
machen zu können denn wenn die
kreditwirtschaft still steht dann mein
leben zuschauer ist das geschrei groß
unternehmen können nicht planen und
investieren innovation kommt zum
erliegen neuer häuser und wohnungen
können nicht mehr gebaut und alte nicht
mehr renoviert werden die welt wird
komplett ausgebremst ja und ein
ähnliches horrorszenario haben auch die
wirtschaftsstarken länder der eurozone
vor augen wenn von corona bonds die rede
ist denn sie wissen dass am ende die
ganze rechnung begleichen müssen wenn
die finanziell schwachen länder die mit
den eurobonds gemachten schulden
irgendwann nicht mehr zurückzahlen
können oder wollen alles erklärt warum
als brüssel mit der eurobond idee ankam
deutschland die niederlande und finnland
sagten nicht mit uns sucht euch einen
anderen dummen gut das war damals aber
jetzt ist die situation wieder anders
wäre es wenn uns mitten in der krise und
das gespenst der eurobonds geht in
brüssel wieder um was genau ist jetzt
anders nun das werden wir gleich sehen
[Musik]
transparenz nein danke
in einer hinsicht ähnelt die korona
krise der schuldenkrise von 2008 sie
trifft so gut wie jedes land rund um den
globus wobei die reaktionen einiger
länder durchaus unterschiedlich
ausfallen
italien spanien und frankreich erlebten
einen schweren schock fatale
zusammenbrüche der krankenversorgung und
gingen dann in einen langanhaltenden
wirklich radikalen lockdown der die
menschen dort wirtschaftlich und
psychisch extrem stark belastet
in deutschland österreich tschechien und
polen für die panik gemäßigter aus die
gesundheitssysteme hatten keinerlei
probleme mit der krankenversorgung und
dieser länder fangen auch damit an die
lok down maßnahmen zu lockern und die
wirtschaft zur normalität zurückzuführen
und nein ob an land in der kroner krise
im totalen desaster endet oder nicht hat
nichts damit zu tun ob es reiche ist
oder nicht so sind beispielsweise
tschechien oder polen ärmer als spanien
oder italien zumindest war das noch vor
der krise so aus dem hielten ihre
gesundheitssysteme stand und es gab dort
kaum mit kurven und in verbindung
stehende todesfälle in tschechien hat
als erstes europäisches land nun sogar
offiziell angekündigt dass es die
quarantänemaßnahmen ab sofort lockern
wird
da die ihre produktionszahlen des virus
unter den kritischen stellen wert von 1
gefallen sei
das leben fängt also zb im frühlingshaft
sonnigen prag bald wieder an seinem
gewohnten gang zu gehen und die menschen
können bereits einigermaßen ausgelassen
die osterfeiertage gewesen
[Musik]
zumindest setzte der sturm auf die bau-
und hobbymarkt ein wie gewöhnlich vor
feiertagen auch wenn der sturm diesmal
eher ein angestauter mega tsunami war
und das ganz ohne rabatt aktionen wieder
auf tiernahrung noch auch sonst was gut
kollabierende baumärkte sind immer noch
angenehmer als kollabierende
krankenhäuser
denn währenddessen sieht es bei italien
frankreich und spanien ganz anders aus
die menschen dort werden noch für
längere zeit in ihren wohnungen
eingesperrt bleiben müssen und diese nur
in einem extrem begrenzten radius und
mit ausnahmegenehmigungen zb für den
einkauf einmal pro woche verlassen
dürfen eine situation die psychisch und
wirtschaftlich nur sehr schwer
auszuhalten ist und es ist leider jetzt
schon absehbar dass vor allem italien
nach der krise als gebrochenes land
darstellen
[Musik]
so traurig dieses schicksal auch ist
müssen wir uns aber trotzdem die frage
stellen ob spanien und italien in dieser
krise nicht doch irgendwas verdammte
schlecht gemacht haben aber darüber
haben wir bereits vor ein paar tagen im
video über das kroner fiasko spaniens
gesprochen
fakt ist dass das ergebnis der korona
krise genau wie das der finanzkrise von
2008 gigantische staatsschulden sein
werden das bruttoinlandsprodukt wird ein
brechen die steuereinnahmen werden
sinken und die öffentlichen ausgaben
steigen jeder staat in europa wird sich
gewaltig neu verschulden müssen und hier
kommt brüssel zu lesen
die ezb kündigt 750 milliarden euro
pandemie not kauf programm ppp an und
wieder sprechen wir über eine rettung
mit geringen wirtschaftlichen aber sehr
hohen politischen kosten denn wenn die
europäische zentralbank einem geld leiht
will sie wissen wofür es verwendet wird
boston der regel zu unpopulären
ausgabenkürzungen führt so und an dieser
stelle kommt zum ideologischen parks
dieser geschichte sowohl spanien als
auch italien haben in den vergangenen
jahren nämlich die staatsausgaben in die
höhe getrieben im falle spaniens ist die
regierung eine koalition von sozialisten
mit pommes und podemos ist eine partei
die 2014 entstand um sich den
bedingungen der eu zur rettung spaniens
entgegenzustellen
daher ist es nur schwer vorstellbar dass
gerade diese regierung neue bedingungen
akzeptieren mit anderen worten der
spanische premierminister pedro sanchez
könnte vor einem dilemma stehen entweder
er wechselt den koalitionspartner oder
er ruft neuwahlen aus die erste option
wäre sehr schwierig bei der zweiten
würde er riskieren die wahlen zu
verlieren und gar nicht mehr in die
regierung zu kommen und
interessanterweise ist die politische
situation in italien ja spanischen
verdammt ähnlich dort gibt es die fünf
sterne bewegung auch sie ist eine
weitere politische partei die aus dem
widerstand gegen die bedingungen des
eu-rettungsschirms entstanden ist und
heute sitzt diese partei in der
regierung daher wird auch diese
regierung die men in black nicht
willkommen heißen wollen mit anderen
worten es ist sehr wahrscheinlich dass
sowohl spanien als auch italien
neuwahlen ausrufen müssen und natürlich
ist angesichts ihres lokalen versagens
beim managen der kroner krise zu
erwarten dass diese wahlen verlieren
werden die einzige politisch tragfähige
lösungen die diese parteien haben um an
der macht zu bleiben ist also folgende
[Musik]
eurobonds könnten ganz europa retten und
vereinen das heißt sowohl die spanische
als auch die italienische regierung
wollen europa gegenüber nicht
rechenschaftspflichtig sein
sie wollen von anderen gigantische
hilfsleistungen in empfang nehmen können
ohne selbst kompromisse eingehen zu
müssen und so kam es dann zu dieser
extrem angespannten video konferenz der
eu spitzen in der tageszeitung el país
gibt es eine abschrift der kritischen
moment dort können wir nachlesen wie
spanien krone boss als einzig möglichen
lösungen präsentierte alternativlos und
angela merkel ihrerseits hervorragend
gibt im umgang mit der vokabel
alternativlos sagte in er versöhnlichen
ton folgendes ich glaube dass wir mit
den esm ein kriseninstrument haben das
uns viele möglichkeiten eröffne die
nicht die grundprinzipien unseres
gemeinsamen und jeweils verantwortlichen
handelns in frage gestellt wenn es die
korona bonds sind auf die sie warten
werden sie nie kommen im parlament würde
es nicht akzeptieren wenn die
erwartungen die nicht erfüllt werden und
seinen botschaften der spaltung
[Musik]
[Applaus]
so gibt es nun zwei sichtweisen die
spanische und italienische presse stellt
die nordeuropäer als unsolidarische
egoisten dar die dem erneut und diesmal
in nie dagewesenem ausmass gebeutelten
süden nicht helfen wollen wenn man
jedoch genauer hinsieht erkennt man das
ist sowohl der spanischen als auch der
italienischen regierung vor allem darum
geht in jedem preis neuwahlen vermeiden
denn diese würden sie den kopf kosten
kurz vor dem osterwochenende einigten
sich die eu-finanzminister schließlich
im zweiten anlauf auf den 500 milliarden
euro schweres hilfspaket das vor allem
jenen eu staat zukommt die von den
finanziellen folgen der korona ein wenig
überfordert sein könnten das heißt im
klartext vor allem italien und spanien
sie bekommen erst in rettungsschirm
verdichteten höfer und 240 milliarden
euro für ihre staatshaushalte außerdem
von der europäischen investitionsbank
200 milliarden euro an
unternehmenskrediten und 100 milliarden
euro über das eu ausarbeiten
nach der einigung sollen die teilnehmer
euphorisch applaudiert haben und das
obwohl rom und madrid im vorfeld die
rettungsschirm kredite oder gar die
bedingung die krone schulden sollten
mittelfristig wieder abgebaut werden als
vollkommen inakzeptabel abgelehnt hatten
denn obwohl sie ihre eurobonds nicht
bekommen haben wurde aus insider kreisen
bekannt dass die esm kredit nur an sehr
sehr schwache auflagen geknüpft sein
werden schon gar nicht an irgendwelche
wirtschaftspolitischen reformen
allerdings haben sich die eurobond
gegner mit diesen vielen milliarden nur
etwas zeit gekauft denn der italienische
wirtschafts und finanzminister roberto
gualtieri twitterte schon kurz nach der
einigung europäischen bonds bleiben auf
dem tisch
[Musik]
okay was meint ihr sollten spanien oder
italien die bedingungen ihrer eu freunde
einfach so schlucken was ist wichtiger
die rettung der wirtschaft oder die
rettung der politiker wir freuen uns
schon auf eure angeregte diskussion über
die antworten auf diese schönen
suggestivfragen im kommentarbereich
unter diesem video wenn ihr keines
unserer aktuellen updates verpassen
wollt abonniert bitte visual politik und
drückt auch auf die klingel taste um
immer rechtzeitig benachrichtigt zu
werden und wenn euch dieses video etwas
gebracht hat dann geht uns auch einen
daumen hoch macht's gut bis zum nächsten
mal
[Musik]